the full title of this video might be
something like how pretty but pointless
patterns in polar plots of primes prompt
pretty important ponderings on
properties of those primes I first saw
this pattern that I'm about to show you
in a question on the math Stack Exchange
it was asked by a user under the named
why mark and answered by Greg Martin and
it relates to the distribution of prime
numbers together with rational
approximations for pi you see what the
user had been doing was playing around
with data in polar coordinates as a
quick reminder so we're all in the same
page this means labeling points in 2d
space not with the usual XY coordinates
but instead with a distance from the
origin commonly called R for radius
together with the angle that that radial
line makes with the horizontal commonly
called theta and for our purposes this
angle will be measured in radians which
basically means that an angle of pi is
halfway around and then 2 pi is a full
circle and notice polar coordinates are
not unique in the sense that adding 2 pi
to that second coordinate doesn't change
the location that this pair of numbers
is referring to the pattern that we'll
look at centers around plotting points
where both of these coordinates are a
given prime number there is no practical
reason to do this it's purely fun we're
just frolicking around in the playground
of data visualization and to get a sense
for what it means look at all the whole
numbers rather than just the primes the
point 1 1 sits a distance one away from
the origin with an angle of 1 Radian
which actually means this arc is the
same length as that radial line and then
2 2 has twice that angle and twice the
distance and to get to 3 3 you rotate
one more Radian with a total angle
that's now slightly less than a half
turn since 3 is slightly less than pi
and you step one unit farther away from
the origin I really want you to make
sure that it's clear what's being
plotted because everything that follows
depends on understanding it each step
forward is like the tip of a clock hand
which rotates one Radian with each tick
a little less than a sixth of a turn and
it grows by one unit at each step as you
continue these points spiral outwards
forming what's known in the business
an Archimedean spiral now if you make
the admittedly arbitrary move to knock
out everything except the prime numbers
it initially looks quite random after
all primes are famous for their chaotic
and difficult to predict behavior but
when you zoom out what you start to see
are these very clear galactic seeming
spirals and what's weird is some of the
arms seem to be missing and zooming out
even further those spirals give way to a
different pattern
[Music]
these many different outward pointing
rays and those rays seem to mostly come
in clumps of four but there's the
occasional gap like a comb missing its
teeth
the question for you and me naturally is
what on earth is going on here where do
these spirals come from and why do we
instead get straight lines at this
larger scale if you wanted you could ask
a more quantitative question and count
that there are 20 total spirals and then
up at that larger scale if you patiently
went through each ray you'd count up a
total of 280 and so this adds a further
mystery of where these numbers are
coming from and why they would arise
from primes now this is shocking and
beautiful and you might think that it
suggests some divine hidden symmetry
within the primes but to steady your
expectations I should say that the fact
that the person asking this question on
math exchange jumped right into prime
numbers makes the puzzle a little
misleading if you look at all of the
whole numbers not just the primes as you
zoom out you see very similar spirals
they're much cleaner and now there's 44
of them instead of 20 but it means that
the question of where the spirals come
from is perhaps disappointingly
completely separate from the question of
what happens when we limit our view to
primes but don't be too disappointed
because both these questions are still
phenomenal puzzles there's a very
satisfying answer for the spirals and
even if the primes don't cause the
spirals asking what goes on when you
filter for those Prime's does lead you
to one of the most important theorems
about the distribution of prime numbers
known in number theory as derice lace
theorem
to kick things off let's zoom back in a
little bit smaller did you notice that
as we were zooming out there were these
six little spirals this offers a good
starting point to explain what's
happening in the two larger patterns
notice how all the multiples of six form
one arm of this spiral then the next one
is every integer that's one above a
multiple of six then after that and
includes all the numbers two above a
multiple of six and so on why is that
well remember that each step forward in
the sequence involves a turn of one
Radian so when you count up by six
you've turned a total of six radians
which is a little bit less than two pi a
full turn so every time you count up by
six you've almost made a full turn it's
just a little less another six steps a
slightly smaller angle six more steps
smaller still and so on with this angle
changing gently enough that it gives the
illusion of a single curving line when
you limit the view to prime numbers all
but two of these spiral arms they'll go
away and think about it a prime number
can't be a multiple of six and it also
can't be two above a multiple of six
unless it's two or four above a multiple
of six since all of those are even
numbers it also can't be three above a
multiple of six unless it's the number
three itself since all of those are
divisible by three so at least of the
smaller scale nothing magical is going
on and while we're in the simpler
context let me introduce some
terminology that mathematicians use each
one of these sequences where you're
counting up by 6 is fancifully called a
residue class mod 6 the word residue
here is sort of an overdramatic way of
saying remainder and mod means something
like where the thing you divide by is so
for example six goes into twenty three
times and it leaves a remainder of two
so 20 has a residue of two mod six
together with all the other numbers
leaving a remainder of two when the
thing you divide by is six you have a
full residue class mod six I know that
that sounds like the world's most
pretentious way of saying everything to
above a multiple of six but this is the
standard jargon and it is actually handy
to have some words for the idea so
looking at our diagram in the lingo
each of these spiral arms corresponds to
a residue class mod six and the reason
we see them is that six is close to 2pi
turning six radians is almost a full
turn and the reason we see only two of
them when filtering for primes is that
all prime numbers are either 1 or 5
above a multiple of 6 with the
exceptions of 2 & 3 with all that as a
warm-up let's think about the larger
scale in the same way that six steps is
close to a full turn taking 44 steps is
very close to a whole number of turns
let's compute it there are two pi
radians per rotation right so taking 44
steps
turning forty four radians gives a total
of 44 divided by 2 pi rotations which
comes out to be just barely above 7 full
turns you could also write this by
saying that 44 sevenths is a close
approximation for 2 pi which some of you
may better recognize as the famous 22
sevenths approximation for pi what this
means is when you count up by multiples
of 44 in the diagram each point has
almost the same angle as the last one
just a little bit bigger so as you
continue on with more and more we get
this very gentle spiral as the angle
increases very slowly similarly all the
numbers one above a multiple of 44 make
another spiral but rotated one Radian
counterclockwise same for everything two
above a multiple of 44 and so on
eventually filling out the full diagram
to phrase it with our fancier language
each of these spiral arms shows a
residue class mod 44 and maybe now you
can tell me what happens when we limit
our view to prime numbers Prime's
cannot be a multiple of 44 so that arm
won't be visible nor can a prime be two
above a multiple of 44 or four above and
so on since all those residue classes
have nothing but even numbers likewise
any multiples of eleven can't be prime
except for 11 itself so the spiral of
numbers 11 above of multiple of 44 they
won't be visible and neither will the
spiral of numbers 33 above a multiple of
44 this is what gives the picture those
Milky Way seeming gaps each spiral were
left with is a residue class that
doesn't share any prime factors with 44
and within each one of those arms that
we can't reject out of hand the prime
numbers seem to be sort of randomly
distributed and that's a fact that I'd
like you to tuck away we'll return to it
later this is another good chance to
inject some of the jargon that
mathematicians use what we care about
right here are all the numbers between 0
& 43 that don't share a prime factor
with 44 right the ones that aren't even
and they also aren't divisible by 11
when two numbers don't share any factors
like this we called them relatively
prime or also Co prime in this example
you could count that there are 20
different numbers between 1 & 44 that
are co-prime to 44 and this is a fact
that a number theorist would compactly
right by saying fie of 44 equals 20
where the Greek letter fee here refers
to euler's totient function yet another
needlessly fancy word which is defined
to be the number of integers from 1 up
to n which are co-prime to n it comes up
enough that it's handy to have compact
notation more obscurely and I had never
heard this before but I find it too
delightful not to tell these numbers are
sometimes called the tota tips of N back
to the main thread in short what the
user on math exchange was seeing are two
unrelated pieces of number theory but
illustrated in one drawing the first is
that 44 sevenths is a very close
rational approximation
for 2pi which results in the residue
classes mod 44 being cleanly separated
out the second is that many of these
residue classes contain zero prime
numbers or sometimes just one so they
won't show up but on the other hand
Prime's do show up plentifully enough in
all 20 of the other residue classes that
it makes these spiral arms visible and
at this point maybe you can predict
what's going on at the larger scale just
as 6 radians is vaguely close to a full
turn and 44 radians is quite close to 7
full turns it just so happens that 710
radians is extremely close to a whole
number of full turns visually you can
see this by the fact that the point ends
up almost exactly on the x axis but it's
more compelling analytically 710 radians
is 710 divided by 2 pi rotations which
works out to be 113 point 0 0 0 0 0 9 5
some of you may have seen this in
another form it's saying the 710 113 is
a close approximation for 2pi which is
more commonly seen in saying that 355
over 113 is a very good approximation
for pi now if you want to understand
where these rational approximations are
coming from and what it means for one
like this to be unusually good like way
better than you would get for fee or e
or square root of 2 or other famous
Irrational's I highly recommend taking a
look at this great mythology video for
our storyline though it means that when
you move forward by steps of 710 the
angle of each new point is almost
exactly the same as the last one just
microscopically bigger even very far out
one of these sequences looks like a
straight line and of course the other
residue class is mod 710 also formed
these nearly straight lines 710 is a big
number though so when all of them are
on-screen and there's only so many
pixels on the screen it's a little hard
to make them out
so in this case it's actually easier to
see when we limit the view to primes
where you don't see many of those
residue classes in reality with a little
further zooming you can see that there
actually is a very gentle spiral to
these but the fact that it takes so long
to become prominent is a wonderful
illustration maybe the best illustration
I've ever seen for just how good an
approximation this is for 2pi tying up
the remaining loose thread here if you
want to understand what happens when you
filter for primes it's entirely
analogous to what we did before the
factors of 710 are seventy one five and
two so if the remainder or residue is
divisible by any of those then so is the
number when you pull up all of the
residue classes with odd numbers it
looks like every other array in the
otherwise quite crowded picture and then
of those that remain these are the ones
that are divisible by five which are
nice and evenly spaced at every fifth
line notice the fact that prime numbers
never show up in any of these is what
explains the pattern of the lines we saw
at the beginning coming in clumps of
four and moreover of those remaining
these four residue classes are the ones
that are divisible by 71 so the primes
aren't gonna show up there and that's
what explains why the clumps of four
that we saw occasionally have like a
missing tooth in your cone and if you
were wondering where that number 280
came from it comes from counting how
many of the numbers from 1 up to 710
don't share any prime factors with 710
these are the ones that we can't rule
out for including Prime's based on some
obvious divisibility consideration this
of course doesn't guarantee that any
particular one will contain prime
numbers but at least empirically when
you look at this picture it actually
seems like the primes are pretty evenly
distributed among the remaining classes
wouldn't you agree
this last point is actually the most
interesting observation of the whole
deal it relates to a pretty deep fact in
number theory known as derice lace
theorem to take a simpler example than
residue classes mod 7/10 think of those
mod 10 because we write numbers in base
10 this is the same thing as grouping
numbers together by what their last
digit is everything whose last digit is
0 is a residue class everything is last
to do this one is another residue class
and so on other than two prime numbers
can't have an even number as their last
digit since that means they're even and
likewise any prime bigger than five
can't in and a-five there's nothing
surprising there that's one of the first
facts you observe when you learn about
prime numbers anything bigger than five
has to end in either a 1 a 3 a 7 or a 9
a much more nuanced question though is
how exactly these Prime's are divvied up
among those remaining 4 groups here
let's make a quick histogram counting
through each prime number where the bars
are going to show what proportion of the
Prime's that we've seen so far have a
given last digit so in particular the 2
and the 5 slots should go down to 0 over
time what would you predict is gonna
happen as we move through more and more
primes
well as we get a lot of them it seems
like a pretty even spread between these
four classes about 25% each and probably
that's what you would expect after all
why would prime numbers show some sort
of preference for one last digit over
another but Prime's aren't random they
are a definite sequence and they show
patterns in other ways and it's highly
non-obvious how you would prove
something like this or for that matter
how do you rigorously phrase what it is
that you want to prove a mathematician
might go about it something like this if
you look at all the prime numbers less
than some big number X and you consider
what fraction of them are say one above
a multiple of ten that fraction should
approach one-fourth as X approaches
infinity and likewise for all of the
other allowable residue classes like 3 &
7 & 9 of course there's nothing special
about 10 a similar fact should hold for
any other number considering our old
friends the residue classes mod 44 for
example let's make a similar histogram
showing what proportion of the primes
show up in each one of these
[Music]
again as time goes on we see an even
spread between the 20 different
allowable residue classes which you can
think of in terms of each spiral arm
from our diagram having about the same
number of primes as each of the others
maybe that's what you would expect but
this is a shockingly hard fact to prove
the first man who cracked this puzzle
was derice lay in 1837 and it forms one
of the crowning jewels at the foundation
of modern analytic number theory
histograms like these ones give a pretty
good illustration of what the theorem is
actually saying nevertheless you might
find it enlightening to see how it might
be written in a math text with all the
fancy jargon and everything it's
essentially what we just saw 4/10 but
more general again you look at all of
the primes up to some bound X but
instead of asking for what proportion of
them have a residue of say 1 mod 10 you
ask what proportion have a residue of R
mod n where n is any number and R is
anything that's co-prime to n remember
that means it doesn't share any factors
with n bigger than 1 instead of
approaching 1/4 as X goes to infinity
that proportion goes to 1 divided by V
of n where V is that special function I
mentioned earlier that gives the number
of possible residues co-prime to n and
in case this is too clear for the reader
you might see a buried in more notation
where this denominator and the numerator
are both written with a special prime
counting function the convention rather
confusingly is to use the symbol pi for
this function even though it's totally
unrelated to the number pi in some
contexts when people refer to to reach
lace theorem they refer to a much more
modest statement which is simply that
each of these residue classes that might
have infinitely many Prime's does have
infinitely many in order to prove this
what to really did was show that the
primes are just as dense in any one of
these residue classes as in any other
for example imagine someone asked you to
prove that there are infinitely many
primes
ending in the number 1 and the way you
do it is by showing that a quarter of
all the primes end in a 1 together with
the fact that there are infinitely many
Prime's which we've known since Euclid
this gives a stronger statement and a
much more interesting one now the proof
well it's way more involved than would
be reasonable to show here one
interesting fact worth mentioning is
that it relies heavily on complex
analysis which is the study of doing
calculus with functions whose inputs and
outputs are complex numbers now that
might seem weird right
I mean prime numbers seem wholly
unrelated to the continuous world of
calculus much less when complex numbers
end up in the mix but since the early
19th century
this is absolutely par for the course
when it comes to understanding how
primes are distributed and this isn't
just antiquated technology either
understanding the distribution of primes
in residue classes like this continues
to be relevant in modern research to
some of the recent breakthroughs on
small gaps between primes edging towards
that ever elusive twin prime conjecture
have their basis in understanding how
prime split up among these kinds of
residue classes okay looking back over
the puzzle I want to emphasize something
the original bit of data visualization
whimsy that led to these patterns
well like it doesn't matter no one cares
there's nothing special about plotting P
comma P in polar coordinates and most of
the initial mistery in these spirals
resulted from the artifacts that come
from dealing with integer number of
radians which is kind of weird but on
the other hand this kind of play is
clearly worth it if the end result is a
line of questions that leads you to
something like de richelieu theorem
which is important especially if it
inspires you to learn enough to
understand the tactics of the underlying
proof no small task by the way
and this isn't a coincidence that a
fairly random question like this can
lead you to an important and deep fact
for math what it means for a piece of
math to be important and deep is that it
connects to many other topics so even an
arbitrary exploration of numbers as long
as it's not too arbitrary has a good
chance of stumbling into something
meaningful sure you'll get a much more
concentrated dosage of important facts
by going through a textbook or a course
and there will be many fewer
uninteresting dead ends but there is
something special about rediscovering
these topics on your own if you
effectively reinvent euler's totient
function before you've ever seen it
defined or if you start wondering about
rational approximations before learning
about continued fractions or if you
seriously explore how primes are divvied
up between residue classes before you've
even heard the name to reach lay then
when you do learn those topics you'll
see them as familiar friends not as
arbitrary definitions and that will
almost certainly mean that you learn it
more effectively
[Music]
[Music]